and then we went to Canada which I've
never been to you went to kanazawa yeah
why because it's kind of on the way yeah
it's kind on the way so I drove there
it's better than Toyama that's for sure
yeah yeah I thought it was like a
two-hour drive and I was like ah Church
whatever it's a four hour drive it's
long yeah and I was just like it's just
a highway the whole time and I was
losing my mind just driving straight for
like four hours it sucked but we got
there and then it started like pouring
it down and holy [__] because there's so
many tourists in kanazawa really so many
I know I know because I was kind of like
one of those hidden tourist places uh I
don't think it was hidden well hidden in
the sense of like when you compare it to
like Tokyo dude it's more busy than like
uh like Osaka for tourism really it was
crazy how many and you're the only
person I know who's been to come along I
I I'd never been before because I'd not
heard much and then I was like okay well
I should go because apparently there's
this famous Park and stuff yeah yeah and
I went there and I thought oh it's okay
this way this is kind of boring actually
I think in my head now I'm realizing
yeah because all the stuff that people
talk about that you can do in Japan is
just stuff that's accessible only by
like bullet training yeah exactly
because like all the good stuff in my
mind you have to like either drive to or
get a train then drive yeah like oh
genuinely like a lot of the really
amazing and fun stuff in Japan you do
have to rent a car or drive it's just so
annoying I mean I mean I kind of like
that because to me it means less
tourists are there yeah I mean I I I
wouldn't disagree but I would say the
like if it's your first time in Japan
you're going to be amazed by anyway but
you know for people like living in Japan
like us where we've seen a lot of like
the more I guess like normal tourist
stuff than more like some of the more
interesting things you have to get to by
car well I think that's why my parents
enjoyed nigato a lot because it was like
really quiet it was like no no foreign
tourists at all yeah it's really
Pleasant really good vibes very quiet
and then we went to Canada's hour and
it's like really busy and you know it's
nice looking around the park and stuff
but I I was like I was walking around
this park and I was like damn thing like
Shinjuku Park is better than this one
and I was like and my parents thought
that too and I was like oh [__] I came
all this way to this damn Park and I
think shouldn't you be better yeah what
else what else is there to do there in
the park what is it famous I've heard
I've heard so many like I know kanazawa
is a really uh famous tourist attraction
for a lot of Japanese people yeah
there's a lot of
um old shopping areas I think that are
styled after Japanese stuff
and uh that night I I one of my parents
even though it's not famous for it you
know it's you know uh Carlos I was
famous for fish typically yeah right but
I was like well we should try uh we
should try um uh uh eel uh what's it
called again
and I wasn't going to tell them because
my my dad had mentioned like a few days
before he's like I don't like eel and I
was like okay [__] okay well oh I don't
think this is ill it's not ill so I was
gonna not tell them that it was eel yeah
so I found this really nice unagi
restaurant that happened to be a chain
actually they had a few locations around
Japan but it's really good and really
good reviews uh and when there and I was
okay cool I'm not going to tell them to
you I'm going to order a bunch of stuff
sure enough we sit down [__]
everything has eels on it like like
theming wise like the Chopsticks have a
giant eel the menu is one giant eel
Scrolls and I was like all right what do
they feel birds are like and it's all in
[__] kanji and I can't yeah but I
know like what to order because I've
been to an Aggie restaurant since yeah I
got this so it's not a meal it's a mud
fish yeah it's like a it's like an
extended fish yeah yeah yeah
it's like a Japanese fish that's only
available and you know not a meal his
premise is
I I ordered like a bunch of Naggy and uh
she's like no no you should get the
unaki sharing thing what I've never
heard of a negative sharing thing right
there's basically one of those giant
like in the cooking special where we
cook that what you call it right giant
Clay Pot oh yeah where they just put all
your nagging and they put like three
portions in that instead of doing three
little boxes that sounds good and uh it
was super [__] good yeah my parents
loved it they were like yeah this shit's
good did you tell them afterwards yeah I
told them I told him I was ill and they
were like oh yeah we kind of figured it
out
who gave it away I just thought it was a
fail yeah they were like oh it tastes
like chicken I was like well okay
but they loved it they had a great time
uh and they I think they the kind of say
I was all right I mean I was kind of
like shoot because I was lame yeah but I
think like for one day yeah is just like
one of those prefectures you don't
really hear a people going to and be
like what's like known in that prefix
because like you know Japan always has
that thing of like oh in this prefecture
we're famous for this this and this
where it's like you hear about ishkan
it's like what are you famous for it's
like we have kanazawa it's like okay but
what's this yeah I mean I I think it's I
I feel like I've traveled enough of
Japan now to be a bit uh be able to like
kind of rate some of the places I mean
I've got like a [__] ton of places I
feel like I can accurately tell you
what's a fun place and what's not I
guess I was okay also it was raining so
it was also just coming up okay yeah
yeah
the day after uh how was that how many
tourists yeah oh my god dude it because
I I've only been to Kyoto now
during the pandemic I've been three
times during the pandemic and it's time
it was slowly busier than the last it
was never busy yeah like the first time
I went and you can watch this in my um
when I did the British town but yeah we
it's in Kyoto this British town and we
filmed at the Kyo mizudera the the the
picture of Japan and every single
tourist picture
yeah yeah and and you can see in that
video actually like we filmed it a thing
and you can see in the background
there's nobody there there's no one at
this Temple
um and it was it was like really cool
and I thought oh this is kind of neat
and I went there this time I was like I
never want to go to kid I ever again
this [__] sucks like it's like shoulder
to shoulder yeah the whole thing like
you can't you can't do anything fun
there was actually a pretty cool
um Craft Beer Stand like right at the
bottom of the street right before the
kill music it was kind of cool it was
and it's a good beer it was like
standing thing it was kind of fun other
than that but everything else was like
okay the views were cool I think they
enjoyed that
um uh yeah we went around temples but
dude I got recognized so much it's kind
of like all right I felt bad for my
parents because in the kill music we got
stopped like nine times just walking
around there's nowhere to go as well
because this is like everywhere shoulder
to shoulder but I think my parents kind
of they they kind of got a kick out of
seeing people recognize me they're like
oh
I've done this three times before yeah I
would if my friends were like hey Connor
let's go to Kyoto let's go look at
Temple I'm like absolutely not like I
I'll I'll come out and drink later yeah
it's like have a good time no not
because like I I I I don't want to get
recognized I don't give a [__] about
that it's just a dude it's so busy for
me I don't enjoy it even for people who
are like okay in a crowd like just how
packed Kyoto gets especially at Nara as
well like those those like I think are
like the top two places where it's like
it's literally like going to an anime
convention it's just like you're [__]
standing like this and it's like and you
can't even get like a good view because
you have to [__] look over the heads
of everyone it's just like is this is it
an age thing where you just like I don't
know if it is but it has been for me
because I used to be like so up for like
going into big crowds or you know seven
age thing yeah yeah and then the the
more older I got the less patience I had
for like big groups of people to the
point where now I I would do anything to
just avoid it if I can I think it's an
age thing because I think all three of
us are there
we're just like yeah okay here's if
there's a giant crowd it needs to be
something that makes the giant crowd in
my mind worth the sacrifice yeah yeah
yeah exactly something about this is
like such moving but something about not
being able to walk the pace I want to
walk just just gets to me and it's just
it's such a small thing but if you're a
[__] penguin walk right like yeah
yeah if it's a little tiny baby steps
yeah if you just penguin walk like uh
because when we went to uh Shibuya like
last weekend yeah and you were like uh
where are you and uh I was like oh I'm
just around the corner 10 minutes later
he text me again being like where are
you and I literally was just like
penguin Walking In This Crowd I was
literally just around the corner and I'm
like Shibuya never again never [__]
again that that shoulders
oh my God my parents went to shibiot and
they told me it was too busy yeah yeah
okay well yeah that's the point yeah
like the crossing was really busy yeah
of course it is yeah
um and uh yeah every night we went out
as well so cute we went out and luckily
I had a friend who
um was from Kyoto who I I hung out with
a few times when I went last time and
they'd show me a bunch of bars so it was
great so I had a bunch of bars that I
knew that were great yeah they were good
vibes and I like it when they're like
not on the street and a lot of these
bars weren't so it's great because you
can actually always get in yeah
um and then um which if you cocktail
bars and then I was like okay I got an
idea I want to take them I just looked
on my phone I was like is there an
airsoft Barn nearby and there seems to
be an airsoft bar in like every city
yeah it was fun yeah and so we I found
an airsoft bot it looks super Jank they
did like tacos and shisha and Airsoft
it's just like a weird combination it
was in Kyoto about it it's really
peaceful like Kyoto apparently The
Nightlife area of Kyoto is like pretty
wild like oh yeah it's very loud and
touristy can't say I think in general is
like very loud so I was like yeah I
found this bar and I was like [__] it
let's go so I took my parents to the
shooting bar and I'm like yeah pick a
gun we'll go shoot we'll shoot it in the
shooting range
so I'm like you have a Japanese
experience yeah
not getting what's happening yeah my
dad's like oh well I'll shoot this one
my mom's like I don't I don't want to
shoot anything just shoot a gun shooter
so she picks like the like the Desert
Eagle or something yeah and they they
stick her in this range I think she
really enjoyed it she was having a good
time yeah I picked like the most big gun
I was like give me the biggest one you
got so the grenade launcher yeah they
gave me like some giant assault rifle
thing and I just started [__] they
were all like they were okay and I was
like all right let me show you how I
sound like I was like that's gaming and
I did pretty good of course but yeah but
more importantly uh there is such a
weird bar and then after that I was like
we've got to find some weird ass salary
Man karaoke bar that isn't on the street
right it's got to be on like the fourth
floor yeah and I found this bar with it
was this is a weird karaoke bar
um there was like a mismatch of like
there was like a tatami area with like
game consoles and there was like lawn
chairs in this other Corner because my
parents wanted to do karaoke and at
first they were like no no I don't want
to do any songs and I was like yeah I'll
sing I'll sing so sang and then
eventually they were kind of like I
guess we'll do one song and then they
got two into it and I was like all right
we're gonna go now stop stop queuing
songs and she's like yeah we'll go we'll
go and then as we're standing up my
mom's putting in another [__] song
I'm like Mom we gotta go just one more
song please yeah yeah and there's a lot
of karaoke and the I think the Japanese
uh bar owner was like what the [__] is
going what the [__] is this because our
friend came with us as well and he was
[__] awful at singing and he was
screaming I of course Eugene would be of
course of course he would be off pit he
doesn't he doesn't strike me as a bit of
a singer he was like all off Pitch
screaming and then this guy was smoking
his cigarettes before we came in in a
moment when our friend started singing
he was like all right I'm out see ya
they just laughed and then I went in the
toilet and it was I posted on Twitter
the tiny ass uh toilet and I'm taking a
piss and just a cockroach just walks
over my foot and I was like yeah that
seems about right yeah I was like oh God
you're all right at home oh God you know
I kind of love the vibe of those bars
you find no I do I love them because you
know there are so many bars nowadays
where you know people think about oh
what's the concept of this bar what's
the selling point of this bar and then
you find places like the airsoft shisha
place and it's just like some guy drunk
at 3am being like dude they were like
just Bros yeah yeah super chill they
were like what do you want to do yeah I
was like I feel like opening a bar what
should we have
some like really nice ones really like
good sit-down ones but also a bunch of
weird ones yeah and the next day we uh
oh dude like I was really shocked I my
parents are like how are we getting to
All Star girls like I don't know I'll
figure it out in the morning it can't be
and I took this for granted like I think
people when they come to Japan like they
feel really like intimidated by like
transporting and getting places yeah and
I guess because we've just done it so
goddamn much it's like dude there's
always a way yeah there's all you don't
need to worry about it you can figure it
out in the morning yeah and like luckily
because I I knew that
um uh I'll sucking Kyoto super close I
was like yeah sure there's 30 minutes
away yeah I'm sure there's like commuter
trains that you can get so it's like
don't worry about it and they happen to
be a train station in like uh that had
this train that went all the way there
and it was more of like a kind of like a
hybrid between a commuter train and like
a shinkansen where it was like all the
trains were laid out like uh like
shinkansen's where you get like a seat
and table yeah and I found this train I
don't know why I'm gonna be like a train
nerd for a second even though I don't
normally care I so we went to this like
normal ass train right
and then we go down to the platform and
there was like this kiosk on the
platform where you could buy tickets to
the premium car the green car not the
green car because this is like a
different line entirely right right they
had their own branding and [__] and it
was like a kiosk it was like if you want
to go in the premium car you're going to
pay to upgrade here and I thought okay
[__] it let's see what it is so go up to
the thing uh bear in mind this whole
journey from uh Kyoto to Osaka it was
like 300 Yen yeah uh because it's like a
normal ass Transportation train super
close um and so I thought okay well how
much could it be like so I go to this
thing and it's it's 500 yen to upgrade
to this like luxury train I thought oh
let's do it sure let's see what it is we
get in dude it's like the nicest thing
ever it's like this train is immaculate
these seats are incredible and it had
like a chauffeur in the [__] seat I
couldn't believe this thing wow I was
like 500 yen in the UK this would cost
like 400 quid yeah just to upgrade to
this I was like holy [__] dude it was so
cool I just and I just got such a like
that made me so happy just finding that
out and that we just got on that thing
and it was super nice and not the first
class of commuter trains it's just
randomly found this premium ass and I
wouldn't have found it unless I just
happened to walk past that section of
the car because they had these two
things so you could just pay with your
suitcase upgrade it I thought dude
that's sick and then the moment you walk
onto the premium car there's like
someone is like immediately like show me
your tickets to the premium car he's all
dressed up like a like really fancy yeah
yeah this is sick this is so sick oh
yeah